hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I'm your girl
Jacqueline alongside my co-host Mr Mark
Ellis how are you doing sir oh
Jacqueline it's that time of the year
where we're getting very excited not
necessarily about the fall movie season
yet you probably are but we're also
thinking about that other season that
kicks off pun intended at the beginning
of September at where I'm going to be in
Vegas uh opening NFL kickoff week so I'm
I'm just basically staying in my cave
and doing nothing I'm not giving myself
any treats I'm not giving myself any
alcohol until I get to Vegas because as
we know when you combine the NFL in Las
Vegas I tend to have some cheat meals
yeah cheap meals that's kind of a cheat
existence right to go play as an adult
child like in Vegas with like football
toys and gambling and betting which that
is very adult childlike behaviors like
we're gonna play games on the games that
the other games are playing and we're
gonna get drunk and there's going to be
strippers in proximity and gambling and
it's all gonna be fun like this is the
adult version of of sleep away camp that
I want to be a part of because it
happens when it happens I never am
because I am always in the middle of
award season yeah you're doing you're
probably going to be at at like Tiff or
some fancy Festival while I am living
out let's be honest when you watch the
Tom Hanks movie big it's nice that he
went back to being a little kid at the
end of that movie because if not he's
turning into Mark Ellis so quickly no
strings to hold him down no family to
worry about no significant other just
just adulting his way through life
honestly very similar to our subject
today let's keep it real that is what
you call it a great podcast transition
ladies and gentlemen because we're
talking about Thor the man-child himself
God of Thunder but probably we'd be
better off and wouldn't need this movie
if he just went to therapy but we're
gonna be ranking the entire Thor
franchise ladies and gentlemen from the
first one starting in 2017 all the way
to the Grand whopping total of the
fourth which just released on VOD this
weekend it is a short ranking episode
but we have somebody that is really
really great along for the ride with us
Hector Navarro he is I would just say an
all-around awesome internet person in
general he is someone who I just like
hanging out with and getting to like
talk movies with he's also the host of
like several things all over the
Internet including the thing that I was
supposed to remember but I've already
forgotten Heroes I've got Mark Ellis
with me the snowdown champion and so he
knows exactly what podcast is Hector's
mark it is Heroes reforged and in My
schmodown DNA I also have have to
mention that the first Thor came out in
2011 it was Thor Ragnarok it was 2017.
oh that's right sorry did I say 11
you're right no actually you know what
this is is Jacqueline is looking at the
ranking you're looking at the ranking
yeah and I'm not looking at the actual
dates and also I'm slightly blind and
that seven looks like a one anyway it's
Heroes reforged hi Hector
I'm so happy that was such a lovely
thing to say to be able to and I feel
the same as well to to be able to hang
out with Jacqueline and Mark and geek
out about movies I always feel like I
learned something from you guys whenever
I hang out with you I just love talking
about movies that we love so thank you
so so much for allowing my qualification
for this podcast to be he has all the
Thor action figures we should have him
on and I have them I don't know if that
was the qualification Lucy was like we
like talking to Hector and we know his
number so we're gonna Lucy sent me a
separate email just checking you have
all the Thor toys right yeah I have them
all I got God butcher I got I even have
the Serta fire demon let's go
absolutely not only are they open Mark
here's the deal the new Thor had that
great look with the helmeted like that
helmet that Chris Hemsworth wears right
he only wears her for about a second in
the movie The Beginning of the film also
had the ravager Thor when he's hanging
out with the Guardians of the Galaxy
right so both of those each of them got
an action figure The problem is of
course they did that there's no
unhelmeted head for the full-on Thor so
what I did is I took the ravager head
which still works pop that sucker off
put it onto my Thor so I have a custom
more movie accurate Thor as we left him
at the end of the film love and thunder
he kind of left the helmet behind and
there you have it so does that answer
your question mark I just forgot what it
was can I tell you something this is how
you can tell a true fan because a
collector would have kept them unopened
but a fan cannot resist the Allure of
opening them and playing with them in
the garage in the bathtub and so Hector
I applaud audio yeah no that's really
great uh we're a fan house as well here
Mark has been to my house and seen this
collection I am not gonna make this
podcast a complete toy podcast because
we absolutely could but I do have to
tell you Hector I did zone out halfway
through that because I listened to an
entire month-long conversation about how
it was wrong that Marvel Legends put
Korg in separate pieces of the various
Marvel characters of the previous Thor
movie which meant that you had to buy
all of them so that you could get a
complete Korg so I'm sorry that I
started to stare into the middle
distance it's okay but Hey listen
there's a couple different chords one of
the chords the first chord I bought the
first chord I bought was it came in a
two pack with Jeff Goldblum Grand Master
so if you didn't want to have to go and
get a bunch of different toys and you
just like Ragnarok Korg you're good to
go with that set maybe that's all you
need but yes you're describing the build
a figure action figure approach I've
been in that game since like 2007. I
know it I feel the pain but I also I
can't lie I like collecting everything
and anyway oh my God in case you guys
didn't know we were definitely going to
nerd out on some Thor including the toy
franchises but let's get folks a little
level set on where we are I said it
correct incorrectly but when you're
talking the Thor franchise let's see
where they rest as far as Tomato Meter
and audience score Thor Ragnarok 97
certified fresh 87 audience score we
also have Thor at a 77 certified fresh
and a 76 audience score then we have
Thor the Dark World which is 66 percent
fresh and a 75 audience score and that
as of this recording fresh off of its
current year release 65 fresh and an 80
sorry a 77 audience score for Thor love
and thunder so gonna go ahead and start
it off with you Hector is Rotten
Tomatoes ranking because this is a
ranking episode wrong about the Thor
franchise thank you Jacqueline Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong because I feel like
critics were a little too harsh on love
and thunder so my four ranking is very
similar but basically at the bottom I
have the Dark World then the original
four then love and thunder then Ragnarok
Ragnarok is the king it's gonna remain
on top but I think that love and thunder
is a better movie overall than the first
two Thor's
mark
for your sake here I'm going to ask you
do you think Rotten Tomatoes is wrong uh
or not and if so what is your personal
ranking okay with my heart and my head
both of them are saying that Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong for different reasons
so with with my heart with something I'd
love to re-watch then I think Ragnarok
is number one and then I have Thor 2 I
have loving Thunder three and then I
have the dark world four but if I'm
going with my actual like if I'm looking
at the movies themselves what I think is
the best movie I actually think it's the
first Thor I think it's 2011's Thor and
then I'll go Ragnarok and then I'll go
the Dark World and then I'll go love and
thunder and so I think they're all solid
movies even the Dark World I think that
they're all solid movies I know the Dark
World kind of gets slumped in with with
for some reason the Incredible Hulk too
is like yeah the worst MCU movies but I
think they're both really really good so
these are all good movies we're talking
about but I think the hot take I'm gonna
have during the course of episode is
that the original Thor is still I think
the best one
you think the original Thor I think so
yes I said thing it's a hypothesis it's
not a wall yet it's not a lie yet we
have to think about having Hector on the
show is that like as our listeners know
from time to time my opinion though firm
can be malleable and Hector is one of
those people that can really talk me off
the ledge or onto a wedge depending on
the movie
I'm open-minded too we'll see where this
goes maybe I'll change my ranking by the
end of it but uh open to hearing
everybody everybody's take everybody's
opinion I just also agree with Mark I
really do like this franchise of course
I'm a big MCU fan but I think that these
Thor films even the ones that are
considered weaker the Dark World the
first Thor there's stuff in those movies
I love love love love come on Chris
Evans cameo in the Dark World top tier
fantastic moment great moment
yeah I think I'm just gonna be that girl
to be different and be really sort of
like manic pixie on this one and just
say that my favorite one is the first
Thor I love The Shakespearean aspect of
it as well I love that it's Kenneth
Branagh uh I also adore Thor Ragnarok
for different reasons I think that the
taika trilogy is going to end up being a
better Trilogy of films uh it's another
reason why this franchise ranking right
now is weird for me because we really
have two of what was and two of what it
will be and so this really isn't even a
franchise by franchise standards it's
just
in the middle so that's what I'm going
to give for my answer Thor is my
favorite the rest are tied for number
two but we'll get into that after we you
know check in real quick with our boy
Tim Ryan so he can let us know what the
critics were saying uh all the way back
to 2011 and then coming back to today
with Thor Ragnarok Tim take it away
[Music]
we recently celebrated our 100th podcast
and looking back we spent a lot of time
on Marvel both the MCU and various
characters from Marvel Comics
so if you can't get enough please check
out our episodes on Iron Man Spider-Man
eternals morbius Venom Blade The
Avengers and the MCU TV series we also
covered Thor the Dark World on a
previous show and now we're going to do
a brief overview of all the Thor movies
because Among the Stars of the MCU the
big guys had a relatively spotty track
record I say relatively because all
those movies are fresh here's the
rundown Thor from 2011 is certified
fresh at 77 on the Tomato Meter with 291
reviews and it has a 76 audience score
Thor the Dark World from 2013 is fresh
at 66 percent with 285 reviews and it
has a 75 audience score Thor Ragnarok
from 2017 is certified fresh at 93 with
439 reviews and it has an 87 audience
score and finally the latest Thor love
and thunder is at 65 on the Tomato Meter
with 410 reviews and it has a 77
audience score so what did the critics
have to say in a fresh review for
Ragnarok Kristen Lopez of culturist
wrote beautifully filmed with serious
kinetic energy by director taika watiti
with a crackling script Thor Ragnarok is
a heap of fun cue Immigrant Song however
in a rotten review of Thor the Dark
World David fear of Time Out wrote this
is a superhero movie that feels like it
might have been made by anyone and no
one at the same time simply space filler
before the next big Team Up movie so
that's Thor let's kick it back to
Jacqueline and Mark It's Hammer Time
back to you folks I want to ask really
quickly though before we get into movie
talk Hector what is of all of these ones
why do you think this is maybe a
character that doesn't rank as high I
think critics and I guess kind of mostly
audiences as well they don't love this
franchise as much as the other MCU
franchises or characters because I do
think that the series as a whole is a
little uneven I think that the first
first two entries played a little safer
and I think that entries three and four
they do make some big swings so it
doesn't have that sort of cohesive
vision of like we know what this
character is for like for example with
Peter Parker Tom Holland or even with
Tony Stark Robert Downey Jr and I also
think that just at the core of it Thor
the character
should not be everyone's favorite
superhero he's kind of an acquired taste
it's a really out there concept I don't
think that most Marvel characters are
designed to try to be appealing to
everyone except for maybe Spider-Man and
I think that Thor falls into this
category of like he is very bombastic
and up erratic and Theatrical and
Fantastical but also silly and goofy and
epic at the same time and so if
audiences and critics just kind of don't
buy into that and that's not their
flavor then they're gonna I think
gravitate towards other types of Marvel
Superheroes MCU characters so like Thor
is not should not be everyone's favorite
superhero but to some people he is their
favorite superhero and I think that
that's awesome you know I Hector makes a
lot of interesting points too I just
feel like Thor
um isn't it still isn't as well known
from being a superhero you you people I
think know the name Thor and they equate
him with Norse mythology but actually
being the lead of a superhero movie or
being a comic book I just don't think
that it ever Rose to the level of a a
Superman or even a a Spider-Man or an
Iron Man and so when you look at how the
MCU sort of kick things off I think Iron
Man was clearly the right play and then
they had a character that I think is
what is more recognizable with the
Incredible Hulk next and then Thor is
such an interesting experiment because
that was really the litmus test for me
anyway for the MCU being viable as a
ongoing franchise as an ongoing
storytelling monolith and it because of
Thor's success I think is why we still
have the MCU today because if any one of
those movies leading up to the Avengers
is a dud then you probably don't have
the MCU to the same level that we get to
experience it now and I think a big
reason for that being so successful is
that people bought into Thor we Robert
Downey Jr's Iron Man that in retrospect
anyways is slam dunk the Incredible Hulk
we love seeing a big green guy Thor was
the ultimate test and it passed I mean
yeah I think it is
absolutely a test it was definitely a
critical time in the MCU which we can
sort of break down the very long 11-year
Journey that we've had with Thor to sort
of ranking this franchise when we break
down the four films within it in movie
talk so Brian cue the music
[Music]
so actually let me just ask you maybe
about your bottom pick why do you feel
so strongly that Thor the Dark World
should absolutely be worse than love and
thunder because you definitely talked
about what you thought London Thunder
didn't deserve to be there but yeah why
why that I think that you guys have done
a great job of of praising why that
first Thor film is great and it has a
great villain in Loki and Loki's origin
with uh the frost Giants and then Loki
uses the Destroyer armor to wreak havoc
in New Mexico and it's all really solid
it was so solid in fact that when they
were making the Avengers movie they were
planning to have Loki and Red Skull team
up originally but then it was the
director of The Avengers it was like I
think we can just do it with just
Hiddleston Hiddleston can carry it as a
villain That's How Strong that first
villain aspect of the first movie was
you cut to Ragnarok Kate Blanchett
killed it just so good a great like like
tear down of the character right Thor
gets his hair cut Thor loses his hammer
it's a great exploration for like
bringing him to Rock Bottom so that he
can rise back up love and thunder I
think is somewhere in the middle with a
fantastic performance from Christian
Bale as Gore the god butcher with a
really interesting story I mean I think
that it's it's no surprise that they
went with this character from the comic
books because out of all of Thor Comics
history that villain Gore really jumps
up as being really really interesting
and challenging for Thor and just
visually very cool and they didn't go
with the Voldemort look like he has in
the comic books they they let Christian
Bale be Christian Bale they still call
them board Voldemort though they did
they did but he but but that performance
is really I think compelling and
um I I also think that what Thor goes
through is interesting enough to kind of
carry you through the movie but when we
get to the Dark World so for me a Thor
villain that jumps out is a great
character named Amora the enchantress
that's a female villain they did not
pick that character for the second Thor
movie I for in my comic book Brain I'm
like that's the obvious choice
so for them to use malacath
not a great villain kind of wasted
Christopher Eccleston who's a great
actor you know and even then just the
visuals at least of the Dark Elves
sometimes are pretty cool I don't know
what else I would have done but
sometimes it's very kind of Muddy so I
just think that for me Thor the Dark
World doesn't really get going it
doesn't have that fire or that spark
until they bring back Loki into the
equation a lot of the beginning of the
film is very paint by numbers it's very
frankly kind of boring I like bringing
back Jane Foster and trying to give her
somewhat of more of an active role and
again love and thunder for me absolutely
achieves that and Beyond but they're
trying stuff here it's it just feels
like the Thor movie can't quite break
out of its own rigid rules and the
reason I rank it the lowest it's still I
still own it guys I own it on 3D Blu-ray
of course I like this movie but I still
would rather re-watch the other three
Thor films for those reasons hey not a a
bad one um Mark again I think you've
definitely already he's spoken about why
you placed the first Thor at the top I
like agree with those sentiments as well
um why why is is are you keeping the
four the four on on your ranking I I
would I I would co-sign the villain
argument that that I love a good villain
um even though I'm not necessarily the
guy who's like oh well if you don't have
a good building we can't have a good
movie I'm I'm here for the superhero
origin story that's what I love and I
think that that might be why I'm feeling
a little bit of fatigue with with phase
four to this point is that we've been
introduced to some promising new
characters but it still feels like we're
not giving them a whole lot to do
whereas with with Iron Man you see the
origin you see the origin Incredible
Hulk you see the origin of Thor it's
exciting stuff you see the origin of
Captain America after that and so with
Thor in particular I felt like that
first movie also Blends the action the
stakes and comedy better than the Dark
World did which I felt like was trying
to force a little too the comedy in
there felt a little more forced than it
did in the first one yeah and with
Ragnarok and love and thunder look these
are really enjoyable movies and I don't
want anybody going away from this
podcast whether you're watching or
listening to it thinking that I I don't
like these movies but they're very
different in terms of this is taika
waititi playing in his sandbox and I
appreciate that sandbox but it's more
relying on the comedic aspect and really
it I mean especially love and thunder
felt like a music video which again I'm
the guy that thinks Rocky 4 is the best
movie of the 80s so I'm never gonna say
that I did a two hour long music video
isn't a good thing especially when the
soundtrack is guns and freaking roses
but if I'm if I'm looking I go to comic
book movies I like the laughs but I also
want to feel epic and I want this to
feel big and I want this to feel
important I want the weight of the world
to be on these shoulders and with the
first Thor I felt that even if it was
just this little town in New Mexico
that's being threatened imminently you
felt like oh okay now we got hints at
Asgard this guy is eventually going to
be in The Avengers you felt an
excitement for the future that was
palpable walking out of Ragnarok and
love and thunder had a great time had a
smile on my face I wasn't immediately
thinking ooh what's coming next Hector
is someone that likes the four movies
really well is I think we all do uh what
do you think about that do you feel like
it it is a start in the middle of the
song Do You Feel Like This is an
interesting Four movie Arc I really
really really accept it but I can see
some of that Matrix code of them
pivoting after Thor 2 which didn't light
the world on fire right I can see how
they made the sausage and again it's
that big swing it's them being like okay
we liked the movie boy let's take a
meeting with taika ytt let's see if he
would want to this is before hunt for
the Wilder people by the way this is
when they hired him and actually it was
what we do in the shadows it wasn't
really fantastic
they liked boy and they liked the movie
that came out after that yeah but what
he did with what we do in the shadows I
heard is what got him his first
conversations with Marvel because of no
offense to that that was actually a
movie where they had no money and had to
be very Ingenuity and if you look at the
Marvel directors they like they like
that yeah absolutely beautiful people
that came from very small budgets more
so than people that have directed five
Fast and Furious movies for sure they
want character people they want
directors who are going to be able to
bring that up and uh hunt for the or
what we do in the shadows has some of
the best movie characters they're
fantastic so he takes the meeting and he
and uh and I and I and I think I
remember them like I think I remember
taika saying they gave me a bunch of
Thor comics and he's probably started
looking at them and it gets weird and
wacky in the 80s with Thor comics when
writer artist Walt Simonson was coming
in and did things like turn Thor into a
frog and I remember when taika tweeted a
picture of frog Thor and people were
like oh my God he's gonna do it but I
think he was just like absorbing the
material and being like this is crazy
I'm gonna do this movie it's already
been confirmed but like this is the kind
of stuff I'm attracted to so I can see
that pivot however in preparation for
this podcast I re-watched the first Thor
I re-watched the dark world and I think
that even the clues for where the
character would end up they're still
baked in there I I still think that the
first Thor movie I think fans overall
are too harsh the comic book Fanboys and
you know who you are they're too harsh
on the taikiness of it because they went
oh he turned they he turned Thor into a
joke but that fish out of water humor is
baked into that first time we meet him
that's part of the appeal because we
cannot relate to The Godly Asgardian
aspects of Thor but we can relate to his
familiar relationships his relationships
with his brother the jealousy the
relationships with his mom and dad and
we can relate to him feeling like an
outsider when he's on midgard when he's
on Earth and that stuff stems from some
J Michael strzinski Comics that that's
what he decided to lean into his Blake's
entire storyline absolutely and even
even going back back to when Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby were doing Thor in the
60s they had him walking around
Manhattan and people in Manhattan you
know the the background characters of
these Comics that look like the cast of
Mad Men all these white men and business
hats are like look at this look at this
what is he doing here New York this is
crazy that's part of the whole appeal of
the character and I also think that
if we're talking about some of the
retcons I loved the retconning of taika
ytt actually showing us Jane Foster and
Thor's like relationship in love and
thunder just the flashbacks of that and
I felt like those flashbacks still fit
into the time period of the Dark World
but they still feel like the Thor that's
a little bit more relaxed a little bit
more kind of modern and human and the
other thing and I want to underline we
were talking about Jacqueline about how
weird it is to rank these movies The
other thing I want to mention too is
that like I'm also taking into
consideration whatever they did with
these characters in The Avengers films
with Thor goes through an end game is a
huge part of the reason I love Ragnarok
and love and thunder as bookends you
know and that's something that even if
it wasn't taika initiating that he went
in and he helped with the script he went
in and kind of massaged the lines that
Thor was saying to make him sound more
like the Ragnarok Thor and I think it
just it's a great you know story arc in
there and even whatever he goes through
within uh Avengers Ultron which isn't a
whole lot you can still look at that and
go he spent years on Earth with these
superhero characters maybe that's why he
loosened up his language a little bit by
the time we get to Ragnarok and he talks
more like serger son of a [ __ ] you're
still alive like it it's it you know you
kind of have to look at that whole
bigger picture of the energy yeah just
the way that he does the video game
scene which actually from what I heard
was actually Hemsworth that suggested
the video game scene from yeah some
characters with me on that one but it's
just that it's just that sort of little
this guy is now not a fish out of water
but he is weird enough that he is a 35
year old dude speaking in iambic
pentameter to a 15 year old across the
again this is this is your franchise
Mark I will say that's the Brilliance of
it to me and well in sports we always
say you're drinking the Kool-Aid and so
with movies I call it eating the popcorn
and maybe I'm just eating the popcorn on
the matriculation of Thor's character
but I always looked at him from the
first Thor movie when he lands on Earth
to what we get with love and thunder I
think that when you include the Avengers
films which you have to because he's
such a prominent part of some of those
movies is that he is he's letting his
new friends rub off on him anytime you
get into a new grade in school or you
get to a new facet of life and you meet
a new group of friends a new group of
co-workers their sense of humor is going
to rub up on you and vice versa and so
when it's Tony and and cap and they're
just going back and forth with these
quick quips Thor and they're calling him
Point Break and stuff like that I think
Thor's absorbing some of that stuff and
so he his sense of humor does increase
with the movies particularly from
Ragnarok to love and thunder and so I
think that that's a natural fit because
he's with a bunch of really funny people
who happen to also have the same goal of
saving the universe but I think that the
best piece of Comedy that we've still
seen in Thor it's it's really tough
because there's so many great running
jokes in in the last two thanks to taika
but the the setup for who Thor was and
who Thor was going to be in The Avengers
on Earth is in the first one when he
walks into the pet store and demands a
horse it's so funny and and that's also
why even when Chris Hemsworth isn't a
part of the MCU and he's in a movie that
I thought was a stinker like vacation he
was the best part about that and he's
one of the highlights of the
Ghostbusters movie from 2016. this guy
really can do comedy which pains me as a
comedian who does not look like
it's like pick one of the other dude
I mean no that's fair actually I think
we actually have a moment like that from
my interview with them from Rotten
Tomatoes where basically I think Natalie
Portman and both uh Tessa were like it's
kind of not fair yeah for him to be like
nice like I think that like I think um
Tessa was like I just fully expected him
not to be somebody that I think is great
and awesome and then of course he turns
out to be this lovely great human being
and it's so not fair and I'm like yeah
and he's talented it's really not fair
it's another reason I just ranked Thor 1
and 2 a little lower because it's like
in those movies at that time they
weren't quite tapping into the Hemsworth
comedian because his skill set is so
very he can do the drama he has moved me
emotionally when he's talking to Rocket
Raccoon yeah in Infinity War you know
what I mean like Hemsworth can do that
but he's so gosh darn funny and for the
first two movies to kind of put Thor
through that more classical Pace I
frankly I'm like I want him to be funny
though you know I that's what I'm that's
what I'm thinking and then I get to 3
before and I'm like ah this is Hemsworth
being very funny thank you yeah but see
I think the difference is where it's
baked in like there was a Shakespearean
bent to the first one and I think the
second director
um went more tragedy this is the guy
that just directed The Sopranos film he
does a lot of Sopranos TV shows uh
frigid dies in that film and that yeah
and so I really think he was going for
okay if Rana started us off in The
Shakespearean path and he gave us more I
would say middle of the road some comedy
some drama why don't I lean heavy into
Shakespearean tragedy literally tragedy
and you could tell that they were
setting up Ragnarok to be the other
tragic moment right well they completely
changed course with that and made the
tragic moment comedic and and welcomed
by the end of Ragnarok right so I it's
so tragic It Is tragically blows up but
yeah I think all that character
development and stuff is there it's just
it's just under a blanket of Comedy so
therefore people get the medicine in the
food and I don't know I am of a firm
belief that these are Herky jerky I
believe character development is an
engine that idles very much in this
franchise depending on the film and
depending on the moment but I just feel
like that's why I feel like it's freaky
jerky and I also feel it's turkey jerky
because he has an entire cast of
characters in the first film that we
can't even make more than a flashback by
the fourth and there's not a single one
of them that makes a long appearance in
any of them other than his girlfriend
who is half dead in one half gone in the
other and half in love in the first so
I'm like I don't know if I could really
even call this like an overarching story
because yeah
the dude at the center obviously this is
the Thor franchise he goes through some
stuff but if the guy at the center has
what I consider to be a Herky jerky
I wouldn't even say like if I could see
that across it I don't know if this is
something that you could really say is a
a full Arc all the way here's the
question based on that Jacqueline though
it's a Hector because Hector I mean I
know that you're you've been pretty much
a boot on the ground with with the fan
reaction what fans are saying
um since the first Thor movie came out
so when our good friend Tim Ryan is
talking about the critical reaction I'm
just curious what's the reaction to Thor
the character in 2011 and a little bit
with the Dark World more uh was the
reception more positive amongst the
hardcore comic book fan base then the
more comedic slanted Thor that we get
with the last two or because I do I do
hear that point sometimes that it almost
feels like the nightmare in Elm Street
movies where the first couple were like
oh we're really scared of Freddy even
though he he has these one-liners but
they're not comedic and then by the time
we get to nightmare down street six he's
he's basically the feature act at the
Funny Bone so was that a a discussion
amongst hardcore comic book fans I think
so and I think you know I can't speak
for everybody I can only speak for like
you said my boots on the ground me
observing what I'm observing i i i as we
all know we tend to see more of the
negative reaction to stuff people are
more vocal about that than they are
about just like I like that movie and
then they won't talk about Star Wars The
Last Jedi like normal people will see
something like that and just be like I'm
a normal person I'll go home now and
have a life but I enjoyed that film but
the really hateful people those are the
ones that kind of spew that stuff but
not to say that folks who who don't like
a comedic Thor are hateful or that
they're in the wrong or that their
opinion isn't valid I think it is I just
think that my perspective as a comic
book fan I'm also a movie fan I also
understand that like these have to work
and operate as films and character arcs
have to function and movie critics who
had never picked up a comic book have to
go in and be like okay got it that's
what this is this is what Asgard is
Rainbow Bridge got it
um I just think that I can look at some
of the comic DNA and justify why certain
decisions were made and and justify why
taika's coming in and making it really
really funny and still be like but
that's still baked into the Thor
character in my mind I don't see it as
something that breaks the character I
don't see it as something that is a
full reinvention that um completely
upends anything that they did in comic
books I feel like most Marvel MCU movies
don't do that rarely is there a film
that comes along and just completely
I'll give you an example maybe Agent
Carter from the Captain America movies
is like such a great expansion on very
little of a comic book character that
it's like okay yeah we accept this
version this is what I like maybe yondu
Michael Rooker is a very different yondu
than the comics those kinds of things
but at its core I think Thor is still
similar to those comic book uh
iterations of the character and even
when taika was doing Ragnarok and he was
reading comics he had said that he was
looking at stuff like the Jane Foster uh
you know turning into Thor and saying
like there's such good storytelling
happening in this it's such great
character work that those are the kinds
of things that he would be inspired by
to go and put into his comic book movie
I don't know how much of these movies
are made by a committee I don't know how
much of this is already pre-planned you
know we knew that the name Ragnarok was
chosen before taika was like brought in
to do this third film but I don't know
if like love and thunder was given to
taika by Kevin feige and the Parliament
and being like it needs to have Gore it
we need to bring back like I think a lot
of that was probably taika's pitch is
him going I want to bring back Natalie
Portman's character specifically too
because he probably saw a lot of that
nastiness online and he's like what
would make some of these Macho comic
book Bros who want all these superhero
men to be emotionless and badass and
killers and you know that kind of just
like like oh you think your superhero
you know you think your superhero is not
a not a badass you're living in a
Dreamland that kind of attitude I think
taika looked at that and he was like
What if I made my next movie about Thor
being in love like if that's the thing
that he wanted was to be in a
relationship it's another reason I love
love and thunder is because there is an
element of taika trolling that portion
of the audience and meanwhile I'm over
here eating my popcorn like Mark said
I'm like I love this please troll them
I'm enjoying this but I can also see how
it's still a tribute to the comic book
it's not disrespectful it's not you know
Tiger's not coming in being like I can
do this better than the comic books ever
did or anything like that so
um I mean I think I think what's
interesting and I'll just say this about
the MCU for anyone that pays attention
is they take archetypes that are in
cinema and then they overlay that with
comic books so Logan is a western that
happens to do comic book characters
Ant-Man is a heist movie it happens to
be comic book characters Thor is a
Shakespearean uh Hamlet tale happens to
be comic book characters the weird thing
is is as we start to run out of these
Architects look at the ones they haven't
really done romantic comedies right rod
comedies uh absurdist parodies these
things are areas that are in all of the
dnas of these movies but they have never
gone what we say full bore right and I
think that is going to be the next thing
because like legitimately like they try
to little bit of it in Hawkeye but there
will be a MCU Musical coming soon like
they're mad that DC has beaten them to
the to the punch with uh kaj de falles
like they're doing this whole thing and
I think that is the part of anyone who
maybe dislikes love and thunder that I'm
getting mad at them about it's like what
is the MCU rom-com that you feel this
movie is not doing well or are you mad
that this movie is not a heist movie are
you mad that this movie's not a western
which are a little bit more palatable in
this Sphere for a lot of people and I
get why but it doesn't mean they aren't
valid I think it's rom-coms just like
because when you watch a rom-com you can
watch Tom Hanks and Meg Ryan fall in
love and it's like good for them but
you're not they didn't save the world
you know and so if you've seen 10 15 20
movies leading up to that Mark Wait a
Minute didn't they save Seattle I'm
pretty sure they saved Seattle in that
one movie I thought you know what now
that I think about it they met at the
top of the Empire State Building because
King Kong was climbing it and so they
had to knock him off that is right
um but it's like we've seen you know
every avenger movie up to that point
with humor and with some relationship
trauma turmoil love whatever you want to
call it but then they save the world at
the end of the day and so if you're
looking at something where the point of
this movie sure Thor saves he saves
multiple worlds in Thor 11 Thunder but
he also and he saves every God that it
wasn't already got by Gore but it's not
really the point of the movie and so the
point of the movie is just for Tom Hanks
and Meg Ryan to figure out that they
actually are damning each other the
whole time through AOL and I don't know
if that's just the stakes being reduced
but I'll tell you this
had the best time in the theater of the
year at Thor love and thunder there's
movies that I liked a lot more your your
rrrs everything everywhere all at once
top gun Maverick is the best anything
I've ever seen this year but Tarantino
agree sitting next to Jacqueline at Thor
11 Thunder you and I were both dying
laughing at and I don't know if this got
if it got worrisome for other viewers
but the the screaming goats were killing
me in every scene yeah and the the
ex-girlfriend sort of weapon battle
between molnir and Stormbreaker I
thought was genius and I never wanted
either one of those running jokes to end
I really did love that I also did love
to the the the the girl mans the the
girl the galendine moment because I do
think look the MCU has always been
sexless it's just the way these are
because they're mostly kids movies but I
just really want to thank Chloe Zhao and
taiku watiti for given us lots of butt
and boob in their movies because right
they don't need to be sexless if they
can save the world they can get laid
Yeah agree agree they should just
kidding just kidding though butt like
Hemsworth but yeah it does I wanna I
wanna make sure we we talk a little bit
about the villains before we get out of
here because For the Longest Time Loki
was the most um I think loved villain in
the MCU let alone the uh Thor franchise
obviously and then killmonger came and
he kind of in my opinion dethroned
because like that dude was on it I'm
sorry that dude was on it
um but you know killmonger hella
even you can get some of the minor ones
like Carl Irvin's character I don't
remember what that guy's name was
Scourge Scourge okay yeah I was like is
it gonna be like Doug or Brian or
something I forgot so yeah we have hello
got malakith and some of the other Dark
Elves let's let's go ahead
and talk through the villains I think we
all can agree that Loki's at the top can
we all just like nod that and say
probably you know it's so funny
so funny Jacqueline is that that
character's had such an evolution that
when I got sent the outline and the
question was what's your favorite
villain in the Thor movies I didn't even
register that until you just brought up
Loki just now no joke because I'm like
oh Loki yeah like he died in Infinity
War like or there's the Loki who now has
his own show who's the time traveling
you know that Loki and they're they're
they're in such a kind of a heroic light
that I he honestly didn't even remember
that that he was the main villain of the
first I know I brought it up at the top
of the show one and Avengers he had he
was a villain in two movies he was
double crossing in Thor 2 and double
crossing in Thor three like yeah he's
he's he is that guy and I think he yeah
in in retrospect he's the number one
villain you know out of the entire uh
Thor franchise and probably maybe even
still in the only because he just had
multiple appearances you know that's the
thing about that's the thing about
killmonger that's the thing about uh
that we know of yeah yeah I mean yeah
you know we don't know yet we don't know
where he ends up I'm not I have no idea
but
we don't know I actually think I
actually think it's hella to be honest
with you if you're asking me villain
because I think Loki is a more fun
character I enjoy the character more but
straight hardcore villain Darth Vader
Wicked Witch of the West the shark from
Jaws that's hella because hella you're
not spending a scene reasoning with
hella you know you might you might get
one line about like hey remember when we
were brother and sister that was fun you
sure you don't want to go back to that
and she's just ready to wreck your
planet at least with Loki even though
he's thinking three steps ahead of you
and you know that he's gonna figure out
a way to escape or or bend his uh bend
the events to his will you feel like
Loki can somehow be reasoned with that
you can promise Loki something down the
road that will get you out of this jam
with hella there's none of that with
hella she is there to literally bring
freaking Ragnarok and that plus the
antlers is scary as hell yeah wow and
she was funny and she was funny in a way
that Christian Bale's Gore wasn't funny
and and they both have great
performances but that's also why I rank
Ragnarok above love and thunder is is
that Kate Blanchett would deliver this
amazing speech and then Hogan the Grim
would say whoever you are stop and she
would be like did you just not hear a
word I just said like I thought you'd be
happy to see me like this great energy
of this great Vibe and also just a
knockout just incredibly it's Cate
Blanchett she looks phenomenal she looks
incredible but I would agree with you
Mark I think I think for me hell is my
number one villain and she also you know
being a great comic book character that
they pulled from the comics it still so
fits into what taika was trying to do
with Ragnarok which is he's telling you
about why colonialism is evil what kind
of effect it has on a people why it's
why it's bad to cover up the bloody
history of imperialist Nations he knows
what he's talking about it's a wonderful
theme that's in there it doesn't hit you
over the head and hella is that person
who is literally painted up on the the
ceilings of Asgard but underneath
whatever they kind of covered it up with
to make Asgard look all nice and
everything so I love that that taika was
able to come in and even critique the
very premise of Asgard itself you know
to really make you think like yeah you
know what Odin's not a great guy he's
not a good communicator he's the reason
like you said at the top Thor should be
in therapy it's all Odin he's kind of a
piece of work and ragnarok's the movie
that that kills him off in a very sweet
way but really the rest of the movie is
like Odin was wrong and you know and
it's Thor having to make up for the
mistakes of who came before him and it's
Links of his father any guy in therapy
will will come to those things exactly
um I don't want to spend to his time on
it I do like I joke about it but
legitimately this was a man coming to
terms with his Mo with his mortality
coming to terms with where he is in life
the fact that he is unfulfilled in his
relationships like legitimately come on
kid all he needs is like a quirky little
track and a meat cute in a train station
and this is like it that is a rom-com
and everything that it is built for so I
I get it and I also get why people are
you know having their own particular
thoughts about where it is because it is
a departure and I'm not in any way going
to like take uh take away from that I
will say this before
um uh we sort of like get out of the
talking about the villain section I also
do want to talk about I would say the
villainous aspect of Odin is much more
part of the mythology like Odin is not a
good dude like at all he requires he's
very like I'm On Top you do what I say
yep like that is Odin and that is what
he lives for uh so yeah I really think
that that's like where he is and this is
the film that brings it to it so I would
say that he's the best villain honestly
and he does villainous things all the
way through but if you had me to pick
which my favorite one one is I would
definitely say it's hella because I just
I just felt Caitlin shut looks amazing
in leather and taika made that happen
and so and he this is the thing that
people don't talk about it not a lot of
people are signing up to do an MCU movie
with everybody
after you know certain directors with
certain movies I don't know if they've
all they all can command the MCU Talent
like that would want that's outside of
the MCU to come in to emphasize that you
know comic book fans they tend to be
very comic book movie fans and a lot of
that fandom is very pessimistic oh great
we're never gonna see Henry Cavill as
Superman we're never gonna do this we're
never gonna do that and I tend to try to
I try to be as optimistic as possible
and because the MCU is never ending
there's no end in sight there's always
the potentiality that they could improve
what came before in a future installment
if people didn't like how the Mandarin
was presented in Iron Man 3 because it
didn't really do that version of the
character in my mind I was like just
wait we could still get something like
that someday lo and behold shangti in
the legend of the ten Rings there's an
incredible character Wen Wu played by
Tony Leon
fully improved on whatever it even had
brought back Ben Kingsley to sort of
comment on it but let him be a part of
the party so I think that um that uh
taika being able to bring back Natalie
Portman after it was like kind of either
through rumors or revealed she did not
have a she didn't love the fact that it
was going to be Patty Jenkins director
of Wonder Woman doing Thor 2 and then
that didn't work out and then they still
made Thor 2 because they had to put it
out when 2013 right immediately after
the first Avengers film and they bring
in Alan Taylor and he you know like the
like like we were talking about at the
beginning of the show The the general
consensus is like it doesn't really feel
like an Alan Taylor joint it's not he's
not putting his stamp on it because he's
he's delivering the product that needed
to be delivered so Natalie Portman was
talked about by fans is like great we'll
never see Jane Foster again Natalie
Portman's such a great actor what a
waste of that actress it's too bad so
sad because she was so fantastic but
then they brought back Kat Dennings in
one Division and then they brought back
Natalie Portman and I think it's you're
absolutely right Jacqueline it's taikib
reaching out to her pitching to her well
you can come back I can be Thor also
yeah how do you say no to give you more
to do come on that's awesome another
thing I said dude Natalie started off in
action the professional and worked
through action even through the Star
Wars franchise she wasn't just you know
getting rescued in every scene she did
have like her own action stuff to do in
that too and so I do think she has V for
Vendetta I think she has like a an
affinity and a like to do this type of
work and so I do think it was probably
frustrating for her to see that she
couldn't be a part of that and I loved
getting to see her kick butt in love and
thunder and as SNL has showed us she's
also extremely funny
right it's another thing foul mouth and
funny that's another thing that love and
thunder tapped into a little bit more
obviously than we saw her in the in the
first few Thor installments so yeah
don't disagree I want to give Christian
Bale a little bit of love as Gore
although it is a divisive character and
I think I know where you fall on it
Hector so I'll ask you mark where do you
feel about Christian Bale's Gore I
thought the performance was tremendous I
thought character itself was very
interesting because I mean we talk about
how funny love and thunder was that
first five minutes it was like watching
up again I mean it's just so sad and
depressing and then you see why he is
the way he is so you do have a little
bit of a sympathetic bent towards this
character and I love just the guy who's
just out butchering Gods like it's just
such a oh my God the god Butcher and a
bale in the scene where he's telling the
story to the to the captured kids I mean
it's just so sick and twisted
um but again I just I felt like as great
as he was he wasn't out of place in that
movie he was necessary and you really
could not have saddled him with a sense
of humor that Loki has or even that
hella has simply because it yeah then
the whole movie it turns into a
screwball comedy and and you do want
some snakes so I think that he did the
job there it just wasn't the the
standout feel of the movie to me I let
love and thunder thinking about how much
I laughed how great the music was how
cool the action was and then it's like
oh right Christian Bale is in that he
was really good I yes
you did the whole movie and be like yeah
that Christian Bale kid he's got
something there but it made the
killmonger thing too that Hector was
bringing up earlier where oh no now
we're never gonna see Jane Foster again
now people are speculating we might see
killmonger sooner rather than later and
so it's I don't think it's it's in the
cards for Gore necessarily but if if
there's a strong feeling towards
Christian Bale's character you never
know what they're gonna do with the MCU
going forward not just in terms of
heroes or hero love interest but also
with villains here's here's my pitch for
that is that fans were complaining well
we didn't see Gore kill enough Gods we
didn't have enough of that dramatic
Stakes to really get scared by him well
first of all I would say out of all the
Thor films and out of many many MCU
films love and thunder is very much a
family movie and it's kid oriented and I
don't think that's a bad thing I think
it's kind of beautiful the ending scene
where Thor empowers all those kids even
thinking about it I can get chills I
really love that I think it's awesome
that young kids could see it and imagine
themselves as a superhero that's who
these movies are supposed to be for they
are for children they're from comic
books they were for kids that's okay but
going forward what if there's a future
installment of some MCU project for five
whatever where we see more of the
Fallout of what Gore did and even that
could affect some of the god characters
that we met at Russell Crowe and his son
Hercules played by Brett Goldstein some
of those characters could come in with
well we have to now act this way because
of look at the damage that Gore did and
we could still see more of that and feel
more of that Fallout the same way that
people who complained that Thor didn't
get to have as much dramatic stakes in
Ragnarok I would say he goes through it
in Infinity War right after you know he
he he he goes through this story in
Ragnarok he loses his father but then
it's this crazy zany story he's got to
fight the Hulk he's gotta defeat hella
but it's Infinity war that he gets to
sit there and have a moment and go I
lost my best friend I lost you know what
I mean like that's that's what people if
they're looking for that that can still
happen in a future installment of
something as it relates to whatever
Christian Bale did would he come back to
play the role again in a cameo maybe
maybe not but that impact can still be
felt in something going forward see how
optimistic see how much of a cop out
there I could just say none of these
movies are bad because the movies aren't
done being made that's such a cop-out I
know but I'm trying to be optimistic I
only have four movies and you're asked
to speculate what else is there
like it's not as if they really have the
entire road map there but that's a good
place to leave it honestly because it's
it's the best place to leave this thing
because we ended the film same thing
with the eternals regardless of how
these films are received same thing with
Doctor Strange this like last part of
phase four where I think a lot of people
are wondering where things are going I
think we're still playing with house
money and so I'm still excited mark I'll
let you have the final thought Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong in my mind I don't
necessarily think Rotten Tomatoes is I
think they're inaccurate I don't think
that they're wrong because I could be
wrong too and depending on the given day
I might want to watch something that I
can just get a lot of laughs out of and
if it happens to include Led Zeppelin
all the better so I'll still stick with
Thor I think 2011 might be the best
achievement of the four but but if I'm
putting on a movie Just for re-watch
Ability probably going to lean towards
Ragnarok but love and thunder there's a
lot of stuff I want to see again in that
too
all right well that will wrap up our
Thor franchise ranking talk Hector thank
you so much for joining us sir uh please
let folks know where they can find and
follow you on social media thank you so
much for having me this was a pleasure
and a highlight of my week and you can
find me online at uh Hector is funny on
Twitter and Instagram and check out the
podcast that I'm co-hosting right now
for La Comic-Con called Comic-Con
Metapod podcast so check it out man is
booked and busy all right we'll see
y'all next week on Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]